la conferencia de seguridad que se
realiza cada año en la ciudad alemana de
Munich en febrero es sin duda uno de los
eventos más importantes en la agenda
internacional para discutir temas de
seguridad y defensa se ha informado que
este año se espera la presencia de unos
40 líderes internacionales además de
unos 100 ministros de exteriores y de
defensa el tema principal será sin duda
el impacto de la guerra en Ucrania y no
solamente en ese país o en Europa sino
también la mirada de otras partes del
mundo se trata sobre todo de tener una
plataforma para discutir esos temas
desde una mirada internacional desde una
mirada global y de ahí que se espera que
se discuta No solamente la posición
europea o la ayuda que ha recibido
Ucrania sino también la mirada de otros
países o de otras regiones que quizás
han preferido mantenerse neutrales o que
aún mantienen relaciones importantes con
Rusia entre los eventos fundamentales
principales de esta conferencia de
seguridad se encuentran discursos que
darán el presidente francés el canciller
Alemán La vicepresidenta de Estados
Unidos pero también habrá discusión
sobre la mirada desde África o la mirada
desde países asiáticos latinoamérica
también tendrá una presencia importante
en la conferencia sobre todo en
comparación
conferencias anteriores Y se espera la
participación por ejemplo de la
vicepresidenta colombiana y del ministro
de exteriores de Brasil